[Music]
welcome to the newshour nato has held an
emergency meeting on the crisis in
afghanistan saying lessons must be
learnt about the speed that the taliban
took over the country secretary general
jen stoltenberg said that he knew the
risks in pulling out troops but didn't
expect the government to fall so quickly
leaving people desperate to leave the
country
the eyes of the world
are on afghanistan
we expect the taliban to uphold their
commitments and ensure that afghans does
not again that afghanistan does not
again become a safe haven for
international terrorism
the taliban must put an end to violence
around the country and uphold the
fundamental rights of all afghan
citizens men women and children
taliban members have been seen alongside
civilians for the first friday prayers
since the armed group took control of
afghanistan the taliban issued guidance
to imams across the country saying they
should use the sermons to appeal for
unity people in kabul reported seeing
more worshipers than usual and no dress
code restrictions were enforced
afghans trying to flee the country are
facing several obstacles including
taliban roadblocks and problems with
paperwork the chaos at kabul airport has
continued on friday despite u.s and nato
pledges to accelerate the evacuations
well we have two correspondents looking
at the story for us this hour in a
moment we'll speak to joe nahul in our
london broadcast center who's following
developments with nato but first let's
cross over to kabul where rob mcbride is
standing bry and rob really chaotic
scenes at the airport what 24 hours ago
things haven't really changed much have
they
it does remain pretty volatile pretty
chaotic in fact stoltenberg in his news
statement there spoke about the need to
continue with this evacuation and pick
up the speed of the evacuation the
importance of it for the nato allies but
yes it does remain extremely chaotic the
us is very much in control of the
airport and of the terminal building and
of the operating area leaving the
taliban on the outside of the terminal
and also at times setting up roadblocks
on the airport road leading to the
terminal just to try to keep down the
numbers of people heading there it tries
to it is ordered people who doesn't
don't have paperwork who shouldn't be
there to go back home that doesn't seem
to have been heeded by that many people
there are also concerns that when as it
sets up this roadblocks although it has
given a guarantee of safe passage for
people who believe they may be targeted
or there may be reprisals for having
worked with foreign forces in the past
that the taliban is actually looking out
for maybe some high high worth
individuals high target individuals for
reprisals so that's is certainly the
concern of people trying to head to the
airport but they remain chaotic scenes
meanwhile the civil aviation authority
is looking at just when they might be
able to lay on commercial flights again
you've got to remember it's last sunday
since somebody could buy a ticket go to
the airport and check in and get a seat
on on a passenger plane out of kabul
since then it's just been these
evacuation flights and special charters
now the civil aviation authority has
said that they want to restart
commercial flights but it's all
dependent they say on if the u.s who
have occupied and control the terminal
will let them do so and as this
evacuation continues that does look
unlikely and when you consider that the
u.s is now considering is now talking
about potentially going beyond the 31st
of august deadline for u.s forces to be
finally leaving afghanistan it does lead
to the possibility that there might not
be commercial flights until after the
end of this month we simply don't know
so let's talk about what happened on
friday uh friday prayers across the
islamic world normally and of course the
islamic world's attention and the global
attention of course on kabul's mosques
that's right well the prayers went ahead
and they were relatively uneventful
there were concerns that possibly the
taliban was going to have a high profile
presence may have been on the doors of
mosques insisting that people adhere to
a strict dress code that wasn't the case
but the taliban has urged imams to pass
on the message that
people should
should really be looking for unity they
should not flee the country they should
pass on that message and also to correct
what the taliban calls a negative
propaganda whatever that means so it
looks as though the uh the taliban does
recognize the
importance uh the importance of imams in
trying to allay the fears of the
population i mean something else which
is worth pointing out that we've has
been happening this friday outside of
kabul is potentially some resistance
armed resistance to the taliban and if
the perpetrators of this would uh have
you believe this is the start of the
fight back although it remains to be
seen just how serious this is this is uh
the
the country's defense minister general
bismillah muhammadi now it has to be
said he's still claiming to be the the
defense minister by default because the
taliban hasn't chanced to appoint his
successor yet their own defense minister
so he's more like the former defense
minister but there has been some
fighting in the province of bagland
that's to the north of kabul and claims
by this resistance movement led by uh
this former defense minister that
they've taken three districts and that
the province of baglan will soon be
captured it's a bold claim but it is
badland is close interestingly uh to the
panshir valley now the panchayat valley
is traditionally the uh the hotbed of
resistance to the taliban it was during
the 1990s it was where the northern
alliance that was their stronghold and
where the 2001 fight back uh supported
by the americans took place from so this
according to uh the general general
bismillah mohammadi is the start of the
fight back by his forces it remains to
be seen though just how far this might
go or whether it could indicate that
once again afghanistan could be in for a
phase of a long simmering low intensity
conflict of which course which it has
been used to now for decades rob mcbride
in kabul for us thanks very much for the
update let's cross over to joe nahle in
london who's been monitoring what jen
stoltenberg has had to say he's the
secretary general of nato uh we heard
some quotes at the top of this newshour
jonah what were the take home moments
jen stoldenberg build this meeting
remember there was a meeting earlier in
the week on tuesday built this as an
ongoing a sort of show of uh close
coordination by nato allies looking at
the events in afghanistan and an attempt
and there'll be many others i suspect to
forge a common approach towards
what happens next the priority very
clearly from mr stoltenberg's comments
remains uh the evacuation as rob was
describing there 18 000 people have been
taken out so far since sunday
but the job is far from done nato has
800 of its own civilian personnel still
on the ground the dutch foreign minister
during the course of this meeting said
people didn't know countries didn't know
whose citizens were on which planes
coming out of kabul such was the ongoing
uh chaos there but you know inevitably
when they meet these foreign ministers
uh conversation must i think turned to
events afterwards morale would be pretty
low you'd have to assume among these
ministers european allies who went along
with the u.s decision to withdraw
because they felt they simply didn't
have the strength to stay without the us
but who feel that it was the wrong
decision carried out
in the wrong way they've got to now
figure out what to do next they've got
to look at the security situation
they've got to look at the possibility
now that reprisals will start taking
place from by the taliban against people
who worked for
nato
countries and nato missions there's
evidence that that is already happening
they've got to start thinking about
levers of influence that they can
possibly try to exert on the taliban to
keep them to reign them in to keep them
from sort of reverting to type mr
stoltenberg keeps talking about the
gains over the last 20 years and doing
whatever they can to try and preserve
those gains so you're talking about
things like development aid i mean
there's not really an awful lot they can
do but i think the chief thing
that they can wrestle with must wrestle
with is whether to recognize this group
and mr stoltenberg said diplomatic
recognition has to be conditioned on how
they behave and how they live up to
their commitments and those commitments
he outlined as setting up an inclusive
government including uh women and
minorities uh protecting human rights
the rule of law and making sure the
country doesn't again become a haven for
terrorists
in the end uh nato can say these things
but it's now patently obvious that
there's really very little they can do
to actively influence these events on
the ground indeed another important
meeting that was going on with
afghanistan as top of the agenda i'm
sure uh was meeting between vladimir
putin of russia hosting angela merkel in
the final few weeks of her
chancellorship of germany before
national elections there
of course afghanistan top of the list
for both countries and for very
different reasons
for very different reasons i mean it's
afghanistan drives if you like yet
another wedge into relations between
russia and putin germany putin and
merkel merkel is on her way out at the
end of next month this is a sort of
farewell uh visit they've disagreed over
the years on a great many things 16
years she's been in power he's been
around a bit longer and will be quite a
lot longer uh yet other things will be
on the agenda not least the imprisonment
of the anti-putin critic alexi navalny
and of course events in ukraine and
belarus but yes afghanistan will be
there it'll be part of it the reality is
and it is a deeply uncomfortable reality
for nato allies like germany
that they can no longer influence events
but russia
and china certainly can they maintain
their presence inside afghanistan they
maintain
contacts with the taliban and
to the extent that afghanistan is
discussed at the table between these two
they'll be looking for or merkel perhaps
will be looking for some basis of
cooperation some reason to see
shared interests in cooperating in
afghanistan
in order to try and get russia to
influence the taliban again to reign
them in to prevent them from reverting
to type to try desperately to retain
some of the advances of the last 20
years not least of course uh rights for
women and girls minorities
and so on
joan hull in london thanks very much for
the update
well in around 20 minutes time at 15 30
gmt i'll be speaking to nato secretary
general jen stoltenberg about the
situation in afghanistan here on the
newshour
now german broadcaster deutsche welle
says a family member of one of its
journalists was shot dead during a house
search rights groups are urging
governments to step up efforts to
evacuate and protect journalists in the
country the committee to protect
journalists is warning that women are
particularly at risk and it says that
the taliban took power two prominent
female journalists have been barred from
their jobs and they document the homes
of media workers raided and others
attack while covering recent protests in
jalalabad
while stephen butler is a program
coordinator at the committee to protect
journalists he says many journalists are
being targeted by the taliban and those
trying to leave are struggling
the taliban spokesman two days ago said
that they were going to respect the free
and independent press under
laid down conditions
um and we've seen the the very prominent
um you know
news program on on tolo news that's
continuing to operate
uh including
sending out their their women reporters
and having women cast newscasters
um
but on the streets it can be a very
different story uh it's not clear that
the you know taliban
uh you know
militants who are on the streets in
kabul or elsewhere around the country
are getting that message
uh and they seem to have a law into
themselves and so they are attacking
journalists and beating journalists
and
of course we know that certain
journalists are being sought out
uh by the taliban
their homes have been searched uh we we
know okay one case where a journalist
was actually in the house at the time he
ran out the back when the taliban
arrived and they they fired after him he
managed to get away
other journalists have received phone
threats
uh very prominent woman and journalist
was told you know your time is up and
she's gone into hiding we've been trying
to get her out
so far unsuccessfully she hasn't not
been able to get through
you know these barriers
facebook twitter and linkedin have
tightened security across their
platforms to protect users in
afghanistan facebook has added a tool
allowing them to lock down their
profiles with a single click now people
who aren't friends won't be able to see
their timelines or photos and twitter
says it's working with partners to
fast-track requests to remove archived
tweets
members of the afghan girls robotics
team have been rescued and brought to
qatar the team of around a dozen was
formed in 2017 in the western province
of herrat they made headlines that year
when they couldn't get visas for a
competition in washington and until then
president donald trump intervened
they've since been involved in events
around the world
in a statement sent to al jazeera the
team that helped the girls reach safety
said it's deeply grateful to qatar for
its support which included expediting
the visa process and sending a plane
after flights from afghanistan were
cancelled
is the founder of the digital citizen
fund which oversees the afghan robotics
team she says she's grateful the girls
are able to continue competitions during
this tense time
it's a very challenging time and i
understand that many people are scared
and they are
freaking out about what's going on and
they they are running to feeling that
they they have to leave the country we
are really
thankful and grateful that when we reach
out to the qatar governments
they
give us a warm welcome and
they provide their logistic help
to getting the girls to the safety right
now they are in doha um to continue
their um
competitions because um they have there
are a world cup
world championship of the robotics
called for school ball and unfortunately
because of uncertainty and the conflict
and harass and kabul they couldn't
continue so there was a pause on their
competitions and right now uh they are
in doha and they are determined to
complete the competitions i believe that
um uh afghanistan children's have a
vision of their countries that probably
different how they will see and um
and i believe that the next generation
of the afghan entrepreneur and scientist
is unlimited potential that education
and connectivity can offer them
well still ahead here on the al jazeera
newshour an attack on northern burkina
faso kills dozens of people as violence
escalates in west africa's sahel region
also the illegal trade that's
endangering